so your game lennox 13 it is part of um
the la LAX airport it's surrounded by
the airport it's a smaller city they run
from heart on st. Louis City layer yes
that's why I currently live was living
you were yes and what what is what what
HD winter again at the age of eight
eight years old this is your initiation
to get in
yeah we're going to just saw families
that was part of that getting you see
very people too yeah well I was younger
too but I just wanted to be around
people that cared about me so very
Charlie my childhood preparing it was
rough my dad's in the gang my mom was
never in my life your mom's well I was
never in my life
Oh your mom's over there my life oh my
grandma raised me oh yeah
so eight years old you
I mean so violence comes into the
picture at the age of 11 I started doing
violence I went to California Youth
Authority I did on seven years attempted
murder
[Music]
so after 11 like to eight flight hours
in an hour so basically I did all my
time in and out till I was like 18 years
old I got out been a father I've been a
placement draw that boy Wow
I wasn't for when I hit prison the age
of 21 when I got out I you know I was 25
years old
that was my first term I was but my mind
was in focus on school my mind was you
know still doing beans for the benefit
of the game but in my second term I did
went to school I went to school by then
finished I got discharged from prison I
only been off with like three years
what are games basically about it's
about
controlling controlling the streets at
night and
many ways all my money money and drugs
and their drugs
do you ever use drugs when I was younger
but I haven't used for a long time so
how many guys are here you can
approximately right now we're looking at
like a party one hundred twenty-five
hundred members the young is right now
is thirteen for majority from touching
it up but nothing by youngsters right
now
Negro he's like no I grew up in army
toys Los Angeles City Olynyk says like
y'all and so do you ever talk to your
mom or dad or yeah I talked to my mom
once in a while my dad I don't talk to
him he was in the game as well
yes you were calling you that footsteps
basically but not his I've seen but not
basically his I lived in area where my
uncle was from and when he passed away I
went on I took her I went down on you
know so here alpha was it again on there
and then like today all do you know by
Nam 28:28 I did inside the gang is there
like a hierarchy some people are they
control this powerful players yes
interesting cool well thank you so much
for talking to me you know this is your
your baby over here my step bottle here
your step yes well thanks for talking to
me
I thank you